the world needs more close friendships
that maybe don't necessarily look like
other friendships so what do you think
is important to remember as we all start
these conversations because and I say
start these conversations but they've
been happening for years and generations
but like what do you think the most
important thing like when people see
y'all out like it's like that's a normal
thing it's normal but like for some
reason it's not for a lot of people and
I think that's why everything is going
on
you know black lives matter and all
these protests everything what do you
think the conversation should be Wow
well just go first and say I did grow up
I grew up in in New Jersey and New York
and LA so I've always grown up in very
diverse places and it was never you know
having african-american friends and the
Hispanic friends and Asian friends I
mean I grew up in an area where I I
thought I thought there were just as
many Jewish people as Christian people
because I grew up in an area where there
were so many Jewish people so I think
that that that did give me a leg up in a
sense of of loving and being around
people of all different types that have
been said I think this conversation is
new because I for me in a sense because
I'm now going I mean as I'm listening to
everyone who's speaking and reading I I
know that I to have lots to learn it's
not enough to just say oh my best friend
is a black man oh it's not enough to say
oh I grew up with a diverse population
there's there's there's ways that I can
be way more proactive than I'm being I
can't just be to sit back and go oh no
I'm cool I have a black best friend I
mean that's that's BS I there's plenty
of ways that I haven't been being being
proactive in my own life and my own
privilege and I'm really learning that
now I'm taking this opportunity to to
really listen and to really learn and
see how I can improve my way of being as
well when kids when you're a kid you
don't look at color your friends are
your friends you know what I mean and
it's not till your parents get you know
into your head or outside influences get
into your head and tell you that people
are different than you are you know so I
incur
every one who is not a minority or not a
person of color to really learn about
people of color and by listening and
doing your research it's it's it's it's
it's very very it's very very scary too
to be judged by the color of your skin
it's happened to me quite a bit my my
whole life you know what I mean even
even how people describe me on Scrubs
I'm the black guy from scrubs you know
what I mean I'm not even one of the
actors from scrubs
I'm the black guy from scrubs and so I
encourage everyone to just first of all
educate yourself that's wow most
important you know what I mean once you
educate yourself you'll you'll be able
to see that you know everyone pretty
much is the same we might do things
differently but we all are the same and
together we can abolish racism and it's
everywhere
and once you also once you recognize
that once you recognize racism is
everywhere it's it never left it's
always been here you know what I mean
it's not a surprise that this is going
on right now
it's it's finally coming to a head is
what's happening it's been here forever
and once you start once you don't take
that for granted and you recognize that
there's racism out there you'll start
checking yourself you'll start checking
yourself believe it or not it's
interesting like people are so afraid to
talk to our kids but those kids are the
ones that were helping shape and mulch
with those ideals and those you know
those conversations I think are just as
important to have with your
five-year-old that it is to have with
your mom like you know I'm saying like
but it's it's it's so good thank you
guys for being open to talking about I
know it's not a comfortable position for
a lot of people but sometimes it's good
to get uncomfortable because I don't
feel like we're gonna progress I think
it's we're gonna keep repeating the
cycle unless we keep yeah it's it's all
for naught if we don't continue the
conversation and the conversation needs
to continue you know what I mean
it's not just about police brutality
it's also about equal rights it's about
everyone being
able to live in America the way everyone
else does you know what I mean I should
be able to I should you said you know
walking into a store and getting your
bag check that doesn't even faze me
anymore because I'm used to it
whereas and I was like what when did
that happen like we're at a mall on tour
and I'm just like what and she's crying
because she's just like she's exhausted
exhausting it is exhausting and we're
but we're at the point where the
conversation is being talked about and
more than usual more than it's more than
it used to be and I am very appreciative
for all of willing to learn and listen
I'm very appreciative for that you know
what I mean I'm I'm glad that we are all
taking steps in the right direction we
have a long way to go but we're taking
steps in the right direction
unless you're learning so I'm I'm with
you there subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going